oh my goodness what a stop robbery in
overtime what a save the save of the
night bler on the attack C what a sh steart
Skinner flashing out the right P I talked to
him this morning he loves to hear those stews in
the crowd he gets it on that one what a beautiful
save coming across with the right pad a Savanah
JB paner R shot sa getner keeps Edmonton's Ops
alive going to the right now he comes back
to the left as he's going down he doesn't
just plunge across face first he keeps himself at
least upright a little bit it's McTavish looking
for vrono drops it back strome holding shooting
blocked off by Russ Brian Russ sell it out for
his team and keeps it 2-1 and now jar a huge
save on Str you got to love it how about Brian
Russ ruer Tristan jar I don't know maybe a Ste
dinner maybe something even better after that
one Ro they work it around the perimeter snap
out on the way kick out stop rebound Johansson
just that close Johansson gets this one on a
t for him keer gets a piece of with the glove
yeah right up the elbow off the crossbar
double elbow capitals need another clutch
save from keer against Jew ericon off the
head fake swoops in and a pad save by the
scalling keer the shootout continues always
compete never quit and he threw up the right
pad feeds it over kyou pavich kyou stop by Mar
a terrific save off kyou from the circle well
we've got to look at this maram save a number of
times kyou wide open net look at the effort by
markom point streak working here as
well all alone it's jender back hit
save left hand AER somehow house stayed
with what a save the save of the night
for Jak gondre as they stand and salute
oh yeah they are showering him with Ador
brilliant here's okon centering it for jar a
spectacular stop on Frederick Olson wow just
he makes it look easy when jars is at his best
he's not overly animated he's not flying out
of his cage crossy byro jry are you kidding
me ridiculous stop it's his night and hear
the fans star to yell jari I love it I love
[Music] it side of the net tipped by Ras Buon
didn't even get it on goal that time they did
and sokin made a fantastic save on the doorstep
against Comer but Comer denied in tight by the
left leg of ilas sokin here's Dylan Lin lost
it but stays with it to a Breck it oh my gosh
oh my goodness what a stop by Bren robbery and
overtime by the Islanders that finder they'll
be Chia and they'll be on their feet for this
one wow what a save unreal save I mean this
is just 10 Bell holy moly what what a save by
30 stone petrangelo stone to petrangelo what
a safe mono petrangelo into the play petrula
would stop monteo got across and petrula just
couldn't Elevate that puck right off the right
toe as mono goes down what a save DeAndre biller
stays with him chiso went between the legs save
rebound save oh shurin incredible saves kzco
is very very talented watch him go through the
legs one shot a second shot unbelievable saves
especially the second one for him to make the
first one then reach out with the glove and
get the second one final seconds ticking down
Kel a drive it goes wide another centering feed
that would go it stays out just before the horn
how John Gibson in desperation Sid's like he's
looking up at the jump TR what happened right
there with Pittsburgh get her across now chance
R gets across and makes a marvelous save on
Nico oh mercy ATI that is a confidence booster
Central save across oh what a stop Keller back
door through the crease and Keller is denied
by solder Bloom incredible pass and a better
save and how solder blo got over there to the
right with those big pads an amazing movement
Robinson oh by the right pad oh my goodness Joseph
wall going the athleticism and the flexibility to
get there taking it away man that's the good stuff
taking in hard by Roy Denon keeps it back the shot
great stop by wall Joseph wall a great save there
the athleticism and the strong push from right to
left of Joe wall C backand and oh somehow I think
Thea got a piece unbelievable specifically watch
him go across and then out at Deno just to get a
piece that's playing as big as possible Nets off
again oi back to Carlson and another great stop
by Blackwood that time he got his blocker across
two big saves on this power play for McKenzie
Blackwood here comes ketov for Washington ketov
the ra save by flry he just got to the post before
ketv's wrap around May before he's biggest save of
the night with eight and a half to go it's still
22 hustle back to get there ahead of Shan who Gets
behind him Gren Shan dco with the right PA stayed
with him and made a marvelous save three games in
particular he's in front with fly for the touch
Lucin keeps it out in the puck at the side of
the net bouncing around Meer shoots no rebound
doesn't go how does that stay out three Devils
around it I think looking on a piece of Meer shot
great save Joe Hansen with the extra attacker out
gets it back from caprito man sprawls out again
here look at this miraculous save from VTech
vanich and you know he's been unconscious here
recently in front dancing what a Save By Heart
spectacular move by Nature just a better save by
har and this game is still tied at two how good
is that the barzel horback calls for it gets Ito
the save and he made another oh a great sequence
of Saves by Billy husso this is a pass from the
slot nice save BYO and an even better one against
barzel